Our journey
begins in Pearl Harbor, Hawaii,
the bustling hub of the U.S.
Pacific fleet,
covering almost half the world,
100 million square miles.
1500 aircraft and around 200 ships,
including more than half of the Navy's
nuclear powered submarines.
Today, we're getting an exclusive
look inside the USS Mississippi,
one of the
most powerful warships on the planet
with a crew of around 140 people.
Rear Admiral Jeff
Javelin is commander of the Pacific Fleet
Submarine Force.
Facing new powerful threats in the hotly
contested Indo-Pacific.
Are you concerned about what China's
Navy is
doing, particularly in the South China
Sea and around Taiwan?
I am concerned.
You know, in today's world,
we are facing two
nuclear adversaries
where we've never had that before.
The Soviet Union
and post-Soviet
in Russia was our peer adversary.
We're now facing
China,
which has expanded and modernized
their nuclear capabilities.
The Mississippi is one of 49 fast attack
submarines in the U.S. naval fleet.
The fleet also has 14 larger submarines
carrying nuclear
armed ballistic missiles.
The U.S., U.K.
and Australia's
newly announced Orcas partnership
will send
nuclear powered submarines to Perth,
potentially challenging China's
ambitions for the region.
Beijing now has the world's largest navy,
but U.S.
submarines have the world's
most advanced technology.
A key advantage in underwater warfare.
Mississippi is ready to die,
die, die, die.
This sub is capable of diving deep
and fast,
descending hundreds of feet
in a matter of seconds,
300 feet at angles of up to 25 degrees.
Even standing up can be a challenge
400 feet,
traveling underwater
makes the submarine
almost impossible to detect.
The nuclear reactor is so quiet,
the submarine makes less noise
than a whale
in the dark depths of the ocean.
There's no light to navigate.
Construct 099 on this.
The team relies on highly sensitive sonar
while the ocean
environment is very unforgiving.
So there are a lot of challenges
that prevent
a submarine
from hearing another submarine
or another surface ship.
And you've got to be able to understand
those different challenges.
The USS Mississippi,
like all of America's
nuclear submarines, can't essentially
sustain itself
under the water for weeks or even months
at a time because of the nuclear reactor
that powers them.
They breathe recirculated air
and purified water.
The only thing that they need
to actually get
resupplied with
is food for the crew members.
And that means that they get used
to spending a very long time
not only without sunshine and blue skies,
but also
without regular communication
or conversations with their families.
The food on submarines
is surprisingly good,
but spending months
underwater can be tough.
No mobile phones allowed
outside communication
only possible on e-mails.
Sailors have to look after each other.
What most surprised you about life
in working on a submarine?
Honestly,
what surprised me
the most was like the people,
how close you get with each other.
These kind of the shared hardships
you share with each other.
You end up with a really strong bond.
The crew relies on that bond,
carrying out
complicated, dangerous tasks
inside the torpedo room.
Trident
technicians practice
loading high precision weapons
capable of taking out other submarines
and ships
and warning,
understanding, warning
at the back of the sub.
Jack O'Brien works
with a team of technical engineers.
Do you ever get bored on a sub?
No, no, absolutely not.
Every day I come in thinking
I know what I'm thinking.
I know exactly
what's going to happen, what I got to do.
Rear Admiral Javelin says
deterrence is the key objective.
Even winning a war against
an increasingly powerful
China would likely result
in devastating losses for both sides.
I'm confident
that should we be called upon to fight
and hopefully that will never
happen, that we would win.
Submarines like the USS Mississippi
are constantly preparing for war,
ready at a moment's notice for whatever
the future holds.
And the footage,
they're well, was incredible.
And when you think about it,
you've got that nuclear submarine
watching for threats from China.
But China, we now know,
is home to the biggest Navy in the world.
So from your reporting,
having these conversations,
what would the reality of a conflict
with China actually look like?
China does have a big navy,
but they don't have the number
of nuclear submarines, nuclear
powered submarines that the United States
has, both ballistic missile
and also these attack subs
that can essentially travel
around completely undetected.
It is virtually impossible
to know where they are
and they can track
other countries, submarines
that are louder
because a lot of them are diesel
and just don't have the same level
of sophisticated technology.
So then the weapons that they use,
they can take out subs,
they can take out ships,
they can take out,
you know, targets on the ground.
So a lot of war
game simulations
say that that China could lose up
to 70 or 80% of its naval fleet
if they tried to make it
to invade Taiwan.
However,
it would result in thousands
of casualties on both sides.
The U.S.
would also lose significant assets,
including, you know, aircraft carriers.
Basically, Erin,
there would be no winners
in a war over Taiwan.
That's the message that the U.S.
is trying to send. Yeah, awful.
All right. Thank you very much.
Will Ripley.